let's start off with why this cockpit
door was actually unable to be
overridden is that by design or is it a
fault there well you can imagine rashad
after 911 a lot of emphasis was put on
the Achilles heel of commercial aviation
at that time which was the unauthorized
cockpit entry so a very complex series
of protocols were developed to allow for
almost all exigencies sadly I have to
underline the word almost and it
involves flight attendants being able to
ask for access certain response things
certain codes it was very well thought
out to allow for almost everything that
could happen save what happened with
German way Rick the thing is these
cockpit doors I mean describe the
locking mechanism if you would for us
and were they designed to withstand even
grenade attacks aren't they yes I mean
it was quite clear to us 15 years 14
years ago that it was an imperative that
we that the crew could stay sterile
could stay away from any intruders and
so a great deal was of effort was put in
to make sure that happened but of course
crew needs to get in and out of the
cockpit so the way it specifically works
is that there is a series especially on
the Airbus a320 a series of electronic
methodologies to gain access there's a
code outside the the airplane that
allows the flight attendant to input
codes in the case of German wing there's
even a camera for identification and
then on in the cockpit itself is a
three-way toggle switch that allows the
crew to do any number of things to open
the door to respond to a request to open
the door or two if they suspect
something is amiss if the protocols are
not properly
than to put a locking mechanism in it
this is timed so it is possible for the
crew either one of the crew to reach
over and toggle it in the lock position
and it's very hard to override from
outside and that's by design Rick I mean
the problem is if you've got a pilot the
copilot has got a death wish at any
number of ways that you could fly a
plane into a mountain isn't it so I mean
are there any safety requirements or you
know safety how could I put it protocols
that are you know in available in what I
was instituted in other jurisdictions
which were not actually apply it in the
European Union yes there have been
various interpretations of additional
safety the most common one employed by a
number of jurisdictions worldwide
including the largest tome of commercial
aviation in the united states that means
that there must always be two crew in
the cockpit at any time locked in there
so if one of the crew needs to you needs
to leave the cockpit normally for the
use of personal time going to the
restroom is the general necessity then
that another person goes in to the
cockpit at that time the overall intent
of that was not the contemplation of the
Germanwings tragedy but really
incapacitation if if there's
incapacitation or even any evidence of
illness on the part of the remaining
pilot in the cockpit and theoretically
the flight attendant could immediately
go summon the pilot outside the cockpit
but now we have a whole different issue
and some would say that having that
extra person in the cockpit might not
have been beneficial in the case of a
very determined person should this
copilot issue be proven to be correct